I'm going to talk about the issue of
scalability in Bitcoin but before that I
will provide some background on bitcoins
and then we'll slowly build it up to the
point where we can see the issues in
Bitcoin scalability and what is being
done in current blockchain designs to
address these issues in scalability the
key metrics that we are looking at here
are the throughput of the system that is
what is the maximum rate at which
transactions can be handled by the
system in terms of writing them to the
blockchain and then the other metric is
that of latency that is from the point
when a client submits a transaction to
the system how long does it take until
it's written to the blockchain I think
some history would be nice so Bitcoin
appeared on the scene in 2008 on an
online meaning mailing list by a
pseudonymous author called Satoshi
Nakamoto whose origin is unknown and
then the next year in 2009 there was a
software release of Bitcoin and it
generated a lot of interest since its
inception because it went on to become
one of the biggest digital currencies of
our times so just today a one Bitcoin is
worth about $6,000 yet on the other end
of the spectrum there are people who
have said that blockchain is the biggest
bubble of our times the aspect of
Bitcoin that really gives it its wings
is the blockchain which is at the heart
of Bitcoin now a lot of people have
started to become interested in block
chains because these can be applied to
other scenarios which are beyond its
immediate application to digital
currencies we did a video with Tom Scott
about online voting and the blockchain
was not mentioned at all but lots of the
comments of people who watch that video
say why can't we do voting with a
blockchain is this one of the
applications you're talking about
yes exactly if you look at the
blockchain one of the key properties of
the blockchain that distinguishes it
from regular traditional databases is
that of public verifiability and public
verifiability is enabled by two other
properties called integrity and
transparency
now why transparency we mean that anyone
can verify
how the state of data has been updated
and by integrity we mean that anybody
can be sure that the data that they are
retrieving is not corrupt and it is
correct I can imagine that it would be a
feats an engineer a system for 60
million people living in the UK but
never mind how many people are living in
China or India or some of the other
nations that have got many many more
people is that the sort of scalability
we're going to be talking about well
this is the kind of scalability that we
are going to talk about but let's not
forget that systems like Google or
Facebook also deal with may be much
greater magnitude of users but the
advantage that these systems have over
systems like blockchain is that they are
centralized systems that are under the
control of a single entity or a
consortium of entities while in a
blockchain
the network is between a fully
decentralized set of nodes so what does
a blockchain really look like well you
can think of a blockchain as a linked
list of hash pointers so a hash pointer
is simply a hash of some data and now we
are going to look at a linked list of
hash pointers so in the beginning we
need to start from somewhere so we have
sort of a dummy or a padding data called
Genesis block and we take the hash of
this first block which is included in
the header of the next piece of data so
there is a hash pointer which points to
the previous piece of data and new data
then the next block and it's called st-1
then imagine that you have another piece
of data and this is the simplest form of
lock chain so as you can see this is a
linked list of hash pointers now the
hash point ourselves two purposes the
first purpose is that it uniquely
identifies the previous block of data so
a hash pointers identifies the data and
the hash pointers due to the properties
of hashing functions also confirms that
the data has not been corrupted you can
think of it as a temporal evident log
and anybody
can independently take hash of this data
match it with the hash included in the
next piece of data compare these two and
if these two match then they can be sure
that the data has not been corrupted
there are two kinds of operations that
can be performed on a blockchain one is
a read operation and one is a write
operation now as you might have guessed
read operations are easy because they
simply involves retrieving some data of
the blockchain
however write operations are more
challenging because they can potentially
hurt the properties of transparency and
intake integrity that we expect from the
blockchain so a blockchain has two basic
functional components one is to validate
transactions and the other is to write
to the blockchain we are first going to
talk about validation of transactions
what is the transaction you can think of
a transaction is an operation that
changes the state of data that lives on
the blockchain okay so let's look at a
very simple example in the context of
Bitcoin so a transaction might look
something like say ten bitcoins to Bob
and this transaction has been generated
by Alice now Alice has two things to
prove to the blockchain network Alice
first has to prove that she owns these
ten bitcoins so she is able to pay them
to Bob which means that as input she
also has to provide the ID of the Block
in which Alice became the owner of these
ten bitcoins say it was zero zero seven
and the other thing that Alice has to
prove is that it's actually Alice who is
generating this transaction and not
somebody else who is pretending to be to
be Alice for this purpose she takes
advantage of a cryptographic primitive
called digital signature so she
basically signs this whole thing with
her private key
she then submits this transaction to the
network any node that receives this
transaction if it wants to validate this
transaction it has to perform two checks
first to check that Alice actually
received ten bitcoins at some point in
the history of the blockchain so if you
remember the structure of the blockchain
was something like this and there is
this head of this blockchain
so it will traverse the blockchain and
at some point it will reach the block
where Ellis came into the ownership of
these ten bitcoins say it was this one
so the first check has been passed the
other check that it has to do is to
traverse back in the blockchain and
confirm that Alice actually possesses
these ten bitcoins and that up until now
Alice has not tried to pay these ten
bitcoins to anybody else because then
that would be considered a double spend
because imagine if Alice has already
paid out these ten bitcoins to Charlie
then she's not the current owner of
these ten bitcoins even though she was
at some point in the past so that's
another thing that the node has to
confirm that from the point when these
ten bitcoins came into the ownership of
Alice she did not at any point transfer
them to anybody else if the transaction
passes both these checks then the next
step is to write it to the blockchain
now this would be straightforward in a
centralized system where there are all
trusted nodes and they'll just simply
perform the right operation however this
is significantly more complex in a fully
decentralized network like that in the
blockchain because all the untrusted or
semi trusted nodes have to reach an
agreement among themselves whether they
are going to write this piece of data or
transaction to the blockchain or not
this is where the issue of consensus
comes into picture consensus simply
means to reach agreement about a value
among multiple nodes within a network
now in the case of Bitcoin this
consensus is done by getting all the
nodes to solve a hash puzzle or provide
some proof of work this is also called
mining and for this reason potential
Bitcoin leaders are also called
miners a miner can also be thought a
successful miner can also be thought of
as a leader because when the miner has
successfully solved the puzzle it can
write to the blockchain then there are
two main issues in Bitcoin however note
that even though I mentioned these
issues
in the context of Bitcoin these are
shared by all blockchain systems that
work along the same principles as
Bitcoin the first issue is that of folks
now bitcoin is decentralized system and
it's a peer-to-peer network where
different nodes communicate transactions
and other information to each other
using a gossip protocol now the network
has its own limitations for example
propagation delays or the transactions
could simply get lost on its way or a
node could be simply bad this could mean
that the nodes in the network could
potentially have different views of the
system what might happen is that a minor
builds on top of this block while
another minor who has not yet heard
about this block builds on top of some
other block the blockchain has
effectively been forked and some nodes
will continue to extend this part of the
blockchain while others would continue
to mine on top or extend this part of
the blockchain this is really bad for
the blockchain and it defies the
fundamental philosophy of the blockchain
which wants to provide a consistent view
of the world to its users so all systems
need to have some mechanism to resolve
such conflicts in the case of Bitcoin
there is this implicit rule that Nords
who find themselves in a fork situation
should follow the longest fork you
mentioned before what I heard as a
gossip protocol is that yes
what's a gossip protocol a gossip
protocol is most naive kind of protocol
where for example if there are five
people in the room and they want to
communicate some information to each
other then I'll tell that information to
as many people I know in the room and
all these people will also communicate
the same information to everybody else
in the room so everybody is talking to
everybody else the other issue in
Bitcoin is that of performance now there
are two key metrics that are used to
assess the performance of such systems
one is that of throughput and yes the
other is that of latency by throughput
we mean that what is the maximum rate at
which the system can write transactions
to the blockchain and by latency we mean
that after the point at which a node
hears about a new transaction how long
does it take to actually write it
to the blockchain now in Bitcoin the
throughput of the system is basically a
function of two properties of the system
- block size and the other is the inter
block interval what is a block we've
been talking about transactions so far a
block is simply an extension of that
idea you package a number of
transactions into a block so what gets
written to the blockchain is not a
single transaction but rather a block of
transactions the size of this block in
Bitcoin is currently capped at one
megabytes the inter block interval sort
of relates to a difficulty of the
hashing puzzle because that has to do
with how fast miners can solve the
puzzle currently this is set at about 10
minutes and the idea is that the inter
Plock interval should be large enough
that majority of the nodes in the
network have heard about a new block
that has been added to the blockchain
before another block is added to it to
avoid folks with the current block size
of 1 megabytes and an inter block
interval of 10 minutes the throughput of
Bitcoin is at is capped at about 7
transactions per second and a client
that submits a transaction to Bitcoin it
has generally on average to wait about
six more blocks are added to the
blockchain to be sure that it's block is
actually permanently added to the
blockchain
now this is very slow just to give you
an idea main stream payment processing
systems like visa can process
transactions up to at up to 24,000
transactions per second with a latency
of just a few seconds
now one might argue that reaper amat
rising the inter block interval value
and the size of the block maybe these
performance metrics of Bitcoin can be
improved it turns out according to a
recent study that even then the best we
can do is 27 transactions per second and
a latency of about 12 seconds people
have now started to look at options to
redesign block chains to address these
issues of forking and low performance
now
or that the issue of consensus is not
new it has been studied for well over
two decades in classical distributed
systems and there are well known and
well tested protocols that enable
agreement among a group of nodes that
can tolerate two kinds of errors there
are crash failures and there are bees
and time failures the protocols that are
well known for crash failures are for
example raft
paxos and so forth by crash failures we
mean that a node simply becomes silent
for example because it crashed and is
not able to actively participate in the
consensus protocol result and failures
are worse in this case the nodes might
behave arbitrarily or inconsistently for
example sometimes it might exhibit the
behavior of crash nodes by becoming
silent or sometimes it might lie about
the value on which consensus is required
the most popular protocol for tolerating
bees and time failures is called
practical Byzantine fault tolerant
protocol or pbft so what do these
classical consensus protocols have got
to do with Bitcoin or block change in
general recall that in Bitcoin the way
to reach consensus was that a miner
solves a puzzle so basically it receives
the transaction it does mining mining
mining solves a puzzle and then say this
is the blockchain it gets to write the
transaction to the blockchain now what
researchers are currently looking at is
what about if we replace this leader
with a group of leaders so instead of
having one leader who is a miner we have
a group of leaders we're not really
mining I mean the criteria for entering
this group of leaders might be mining
but once they enter this committee or
group they are not really mining so what
this group does is that when it receives
a transaction it basically runs a pbft
protocol among the nodes and then they
reach an agreement whether or not they
are going to write this transaction to
the blockchain so if they decide to
write you to the blockchains then it's a
collective decision of all the nodes in
this group and it is unlikely for a
majority
of these nodes to be corrupt and do
wrong things with the blockchain instead
of if there is one leader who is in
charge of this task how is that
collective formed you mentioned that
mining might be a criteria for entry but
how would you how would you put those
groups together I mean how would we not
know there's some massive conspiracy go
here honor suppose this is actually a
very good question and this is one of
the research challenges in this area
right now because in classical systems
the entity that controls the network
already knows the nodes so this is not
an issue in the first place
but with decentralized networks identity
is a huge issue who do you allow to join
these elite group of leaders one way
that I mentioned was to sort of create a
cost for entering the group by getting
nodes to do work whether by mining but
more recently this can also be a proof
of stake proof of space or anything else
but this really is an open research
challenge and the the trade-off here
really is that we want the nodes who
want to enter the committee to show some
sort of commitment that they're not
going to misbehave either by making sure
that they have used their resources for
example by mining or they have
sufficient stakes in the system that
they wouldn't want to misbehave for
their own benefit so that's a good way
of preventing or maybe limiting the
amount of folks that happen so does it
make it any faster it does to a certain
extent because we no longer have to
worry about an interlocked interval to
make sure that folks do not happen
because once the committee has reached a
decision that we are going to write this
block to the blockchain then that's it
it would be written to the blockchain
for sure however there is a limit to how
much performance gains we can achieve to
the system because this committee is
still the bottleneck really every node
is handling every single transaction so
it doesn't really scale in a scalable
systems when you add more nodes to the
network it should ideally improve the
throughput of the system
however the problem with these single
committee systems is that because of the
way pbft works the because of messaging
complexity and the amount of complexity
involved in reaching an agreement the
more nodes you add to this network the
transaction throughput actually slows
down this is an issue and it is an open
research area right now a classical way
to improve the scalability of a system
at least in the context of traditional
databases is that of sharding by
sharding we mean that you split the
state or the data among multiple
committees or groups within the network
so basically instead of having a single
committee you have multiple committees
and then you make these committees
responsible for managing transactions
that have to do with say data from A to
F and then data from G to K from L to P
and so on essentially you have split the
transactions among multiple committees
so not every node is handling every
single transaction right now but it
brings its own unique challenges because
of its application to a setting for
which it wasn't written in the first
place so for example the idea is also
that each one of these committees have
their own block chains for example but
what if there is a transaction that
takes as an input one piece of data from
this blockchain and one piece of data
from this other blockchain so which
committee is going to handle this
transaction now block chains might not
end up something quite like the Internet
however in one form or the other they
are probably here to stay but there's
still a long path between where we are
right now up until the point where they
are as widespread as say for example
traditional databases I'm so I mean
that's about unfortunate is the problem
with cryptography is that we couldn't
ever use truly random because we
wouldn't be able to decrypt it again we
have our message bits which are you know
naught 1 1 naught something different
and we XOR these together one bit at a
time and that's how we encrypt and the
nice thing is